so Katerina you are starting a podcast
okay didi I am it is called should this
exists it is it's been in development
for several months now and and we've
been working on it will be 10 episodes
starting on the 21st which I think was
when when this will go life and
basically it's about so much of a of
what we do as entrepreneurs and you know
as you know Y Combinator knows better
than pretty much anybody is basically
making the business case for your
product/service startup and I think that
we found in recent years especially that
the conversation has turned to not can
this exist or how can we enable this to
exist but should this exists right and
and and I think that a lot of the things
that we've seen kind of come out in the
world in the past you know several
decades sometimes they may not have been
not necessarily what the founders
intended right it may not have been what
you know society wanted or needed or
even individuals wanted or needed and if
there were a slight course correction
mmm-hmm or if the founders had just been
kind of asking them themselves that
question should this exists it's a very
important question to ask right just
just flat-out should this exist should
this feature exist should we you know
plan this company a little bit
differently to address underrepresented
groups you know this has potential for
kind of increasing bias or inequality or
like a thousand things that we can look
at that are kind of these outcomes of
our paths and if you you know as we all
know when you're in as when you're doing
a start-up you've already been in
existence for five years it's much more
difficult to change your course than it
is at the very outset so those are the
questions that we are hoping to
introduce into the conversation should
the success so is there a process that
you go through when you're trying to
take apart an idea and figure out
whether or not it should exist
well we most of it comes out in
conversation and I think that a lot of
it comes out in
um the conversational process that you
engage in not only with your team rate
as as a founder and you know as a
creator inventor actually a lot of the
people that we have on the show are
inventors and scientists and people who
are you know you know kind of just
taking maybe some research or some new
technology and bringing it out into the
world and privatizing it and a lot of
the time I mean there's there's a lot of
questions out there you know there's a
ton of for example like groups that are
like kind of asking ourselves you know
what are a ifx what like what do we do
with how do we manage the you know the
potential very great downsides of say
CRISPR I mean there's a lot going on
right now crypto I mean it's like a very
um we're kind of going into realms and
which we just don't have a good ethical
framework to discuss them even and so
just making the kind of question the
part of the conversation very important
I think about this a lot because I read
thousands of YC applications and some of
them are for really you know really
incredible technology that I'm like wow
this could have a huge impact so who
should be part of that conversation when
when you're trying to decide whether
something should exist is it founders
investors or like how I mean notice they
think that it's a matrix right as they
go it so there's a lot of people that
should be involved in that conversation
and and I do think that one of the
benefits of this show and one of the
things that we're hoping to do with this
show is to bring people in that are not
necessarily normally part of the
conversation right you want to bring in
sociologists you want to bring in
historians you want to bring in
psychologists people who actually study
a lot of the different processes and not
all of us computer scientists user
experience designers I mean you know
like we're I mean I think everybody
starts off with the best of intentions
nobody thinks that they're going to do
something destructive when they start
off and as you know you kind of read in
the poetry of like Baudelaire that the
descent to hell is by small steps
right just don't you just kind of see
that happening over and over again and
so you want to prevent the you know that
kind of a thorough notes outcome like
all of these these things that you know
you kind of you kind of get there yeah
have you ever read the the blog wait but
why yes I have urban yeah so Tim talks
about this idea in the context of what
he calls the human Colossus and
basically he says like we have this like
divine destiny and that humans will just
build but it seems like you probably
disagree like the market doesn't
necessarily push a product to a certain
place well I mean I think that they you
know it's one of the great things about
humankind right we're kind of you know
homo Faber right the maker way it's like
you know we are the makers and we
honestly just can't help ourselves man I
honestly think it's one of the best
things about us is that we're just
endlessly curious
we like to develop new tools we are kind
of full of possibility and vision and we
see something that you know can be
changed and we want to change it mm-hmm
right I think it's one of the best parts
of our nature but when we do that
without a sense of some of the possible
outcomes or even being aware of them and
nobody knows I miss what are called
unintended consequences because they're
not intended and yet you know but
sometimes if you sit down and you really
look at it you can see them you can see
like if you had if you had just kind of
like taken the time made this part of
your conversation that you could put
things on a completely different
trajectory if you stop to think yeah and
and you know you know it's a it's
actually amazing how hard that is to do
I mean without exception the
entrepreneurs that we've interviewed so
far for the show have been they've all
said we are so grateful for the
opportunity to ask these questions to
have these conversations because in our
daily work we never have we aren't asked
these actions by our investors we aren't
asked these questions and it puts them
on
much firmer ground themselves and
sometimes even exposes or kind of shows
them possibilities you know for their
products that they hadn't previously
seen and that's super exciting when that
happens well so maybe we should be more
concrete so what's the first episode
about the first episode is about it's
it's coming out today
yeah if today is May 21st and and it's
about a neuro priming headset that makes
you learn faster so it's like the matrix
yeah yeah yeah so and it's it's actually
it was invented by Daniel Chow who is a
neuroscientist and he had actually done
devices that were implanted in your
brain that required literally Wow
opening up your head I mean he's like
you mean he's really his real gel yeah
right and he realized that this was an
extremely frightening procedure for
obvious reasons his it was it was his
his prior product had been called neuro
pace and it was addressing epileptics
epileptic kind of the medical treatment
of epileptics using the electricity in
your brain right mhm and which makes
sense me but had had been it was very
difficult to get people over that hump
of you know putting literally like
cutting her skull open and planting a
device on your brain and so he decided
to go with a new product that you know
you can still affect the brain right but
you don't have to be as invasive so
super interesting a lot of ethical
implications it's specifically designed
around sports and if it works so much
learning could happen it's almost
science fiction yeah right it's like
almost science fiction you put up
there's this movie from the 70s called
fantastic planet it's a French movie and
literally the people in it in the
science fiction movie put on a headset
and boom learn everything right yeah I
know right and so it's kind of its kind
of sci-fi in that way right I was always
a big science-fiction fan and
so part of the reason that I love
frankly these conversations is because
they're all about that kind of
possibility what if what if hey you know
whatever science fiction also has a very
strong utopian of course and dystopian
you know kind of you know interests like
it focuses on those two potential
outcomes frequently that's one of the
things that I've learned recently that
has been so interesting is that big
companies are starting to hire science
fiction writers oh really good to map
out these possibility exactly because
that is what they have been doing that's
kind of what their job is right as
science fiction writers are just kind of
future scenario planners right exactly
yeah no it's amazing yeah so okay so
this is kind of reframing the show to me
I previously thought it was more about
criticizing things that currently exist
so is that happening or is it more about
future ideas in there oh no it's it's
more about kind of taking something
leading-edge great that's actually
leading edge and is something that is
coming soon gosh and is even in market
right and and sometimes they're in
market something sometimes they're still
in the kind of early development stage
but having those conversations at the
very early time of those because I mean
there's a lot of criticism online of
things what are they exist and I think
that if you read your op-ed of you know
kind of your daily paper you will find a
lot of that but what we're trying to do
is really kind of you know start it
where we are
yeah with new products and and and and
in some ways that's it's kind of the
most fun it's also way more optimistic I
mean the dystopian stuff it can be I
mean you could just sit around and
criticize the existing technology like
all day long yeah I mean you know and
it's actually very gratifying like
putting down celebrities kind of way
yeah yeah but you know I think that the
goal of this show is actually much more
about possibility right then shutting
stuff down mmm so this is a little bit
of a sign up but I did have a question
about current
existing technologies so if you say were
an employee at a company where you're
like I don't know if this should exist
what how do you think about that idea
now because it's no longer like if
you're working at a hardware store or
fifty years ago you know I gotta know I
just felt like screws and hammers and
nails and whatever you're like right you
know kind of like doing neutral
yeah it's neutral they're not harming
anybody right
yes sir let me yeah obviously you can
harm somebody with a hammer yeah yeah
okay yeah maybe like oh I sold screws to
a serial killer sure but but but now
you're like okay I think maybe five
years ago people might say like I don't
know you know I'm just like an employee
at this company and I'm just whatever
this is a fine salary hey not so easy to
say right yeah I mean I think that one
of the great things about Millennials
and what are we calling the people that
come after the Murrell jamesy jamesy and
then there's one that like there's like
you know after so like kids today yeah
you know what are you whatever you call
them these days are super engaged and
want to know that the things that
they're working on have merit Aaronic
are putting things on a good trajectory
have positive impact and not a negative
impact and you see this happening over
over and over again you saw recently the
Google walkout
you see organizations rising up to help
people inside of organizations
communicate with each other and figure
out how to communicate this to you know
senior management etc so I think it's a
huge movement and I think that people
have started to realize as employees of
large companies that they also have the
power to say no mm-hmm no we're like you
know it should not exist this way maybe
it should exist this way and actually be
part of that influence and conversation
and and you know you know kind of
actually set the trajectory of their
work you know because it's their work
right it's it's really you know it's the
work that you do every day and you have
to feel good about that I think that I
think that we all recognize that
where you know a lot of the time those
of us who are so lucky right to earn
paychecks working in technology right
which is a privilege right most people
do not have this privilege and that we
should consider ourselves extremely
lucky are able to with our work and you
can kind of see change the worlds right
and kind of this has always been the
promise of Silicon Valley we're here
we're gonna change it right
there's tons of that are you turning to
changing the world for the better I mean
yes you're changing the world right
everybody's changing the world with
their work everyday a little like bit by
bit Yeah right and are you changing that
world for the better or not and you know
you want to be always making sure that
you bring your moral compass to work
with you
yeah and absolutely and you have a
choice because I mean I know many people
at companies who feel like they got
lucky and they just ended up there and
they're like I don't know I might be
part of this machine but I don't know if
I can be part of another machine anymore
like this might have been one hit right
and so they they get locked in but I
think as people start to think about
stuff they do end up moving on but I was
curious about you as a founder did you
ever look back and maybe even on
projects where you're like I don't know
I don't know if I should have made that
if that was a decision that should have
been made well sometimes you can't see
the consequences of it so for example if
you go back to my Flickr photostream
yeah around 2004 you'll see the design I
posted it up there I think 2008 or
something like that of the firsts
Activity Feed
I never call it a feat I called it
recent activity because it always
reminded me of like animals at a trough
yeah but you might be more accurate
subsequently right and um you know this
was a this was a significant thing yeah
right
it was it was not invented by me it was
just really invented it was kind of
reversed Chron that we had seen in blogs
and the difference was included activity
from other people in your social network
right it was the first time that this is
actually kind of a period and so you
would see people liking your photo you
would see when your friends had
posted a photo and all of that kind of
thing and you know you know you could
you could just basically see activity as
it was happening on the system and it's
interesting because this was then
adopted by Facebook subsequent
subsequently but the changes that were
made there were very significant and we
could see it all the way along the way
we could see that oh suddenly the
reordering things based on people's
attention mmm not on chronology right
hmm this is super significant we saw
that and we're like whoa that is not
good right because suddenly if you have
somebody you know it's it's kind of the
same thing on you know kind of
television what gets your intention is
not necessarily the thing that you
should be paying attention to it's a
it's a security hack of your biology as
how its kind of how I think about it
because you you're just kind of as a
human animal you know you're like you
know you see like naked people you are
not gonna not look at that yeah you see
a car accident you're not gonna know but
I mean it goes back to the early days of
newspapers if it bleeds it leads right
and so once we start organizing things
not based on simply I am interested in
following this person yeah I'm
interested in what they have to say
exciting or boring great or I trust this
new source etc and then kind of making
it so that not only is it the most
attention getting things are permitted
but you can buy your way there hmm right
so it's like I think that you know a
recent activity
you know reverse cron list is actually
there's I don't think there's that much
wrong with it until you start adapting
it in these somewhat nefarious ways so
you see kind of some of the inventions
that well but then you go back I mean
you you could look at I forget what year
it was but then there was like the rise
of things like upworthy so they gamed it
in a different way
sure so that was like the early days
like sure we can sensationalize
positive things and get in the feed
before you had to buy your because this
thing as soon as you switch to pay
promotion of your Facebook page right it
changed the game sure right like you
didn't get any activity in the feet
unless you bought your way to the feet I
know and it was it was kind of a tragic
thing to see network that was yours yeah
right it like these are your people
mm-hmm like this is your cousin and your
sister and your coworker and your friend
you know name and then suddenly like
yeah
and so I mean you know yes you can
sensationalize yeah worthy things as
well but I think that the problem is in
the verb sensationalize right attention
if I like yeah it's it's an issue yeah
but now both of you guys are doing this
as investors right so cat your usident
interviews my see how do you think about
oh I don't know maybe this shouldn't
exist or maybe maybe cuz do you put your
money behind it because honestly it's
super interesting I was I was talking to
a guy recently
yeah and he was he was introduced to
jewel really which is the which is the
cigarettes right and he would the way he
was pitched this was it's a great
product it will reduce smoking right
like fewer people will smoke as a result
of using joel and he was kind of like
okay that's a interesting claim but then
why would you start a smoking company to
like have there be less smoke a if you
know saying and so he he and then he
kind of looked into it and he's like no
in no way are they actually explaining
the addictive properties of nicotine
it's now what like there's you know 5
million new smokers because of the
single product a single product right
and they recently got investment from
philip morris and so he could have at
the very early stages of jewell because
he happened to you know meet them really
early have invested two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in this in this
company which would now be worth twenty
five million dollars right that 258
Perez
he said and I thought that this was
super interesting I never had put a
price on my ethics and integrity before
but I now know right because that's just
where it is now
and so and so I think sometimes like yes
you can totally get rich by burning down
the rainforest and kind of creating
sexist media and you know all kinds of
things that you can invest in right
right
do you invest in them is the question
right yeah and I think that yes VC I'm
an investor and my my firm is called yes
VC I think we have generally you know
certain categories that we won't invest
in you know which is true for a lot of
funds right the LPS everyone can use and
invest in guns right but like we don't
invest in gaming ray we don't invest in
a lot of games the reason that we don't
is because it's like a lot of the time
it's like you know it's like it has all
the same mechanisms as addictive
gambling and and things like then like a
lot of times just like Las Vegas for
children and you realize that the same
mechanisms that are you know the same
security exploits frankly that social
media mmm has taken advantage of our
which that's a whole nother conversation
that we can have about my opinions of
social media you know we just don't want
to be in that kind of atmosphere if it
has those kinds of properties yeah right
there's compulsive addictive properties
it's just a category that I'm not
against games you know I'm like a you
know you know give me some Settlers of
Catan but I'm but I'm not I'm not in the
in the business of creating these you
know addictive like behaviors so and the
gaming categories is full of that right
and I mean that's why I like the concept
of this show that you're doing a lot
because I think more of those
conversations about should we fund this
should we be part of this you know
oftentimes you know since we're so early
you know we're the first you know check
for the first money in and so that is is
pretty
powerful is so powerful yeah and so cuz
you're basically putting the you know y
combinator seal of approval on every
company that you invest in we - we're
like putting a yes VC seal of approval
on every on every company that we
endorse I mean it's an endorsement I
mean of course yeah of course I don't
think tricky things have happened at YC
absolutely we're a company pivots in
you're like oh boy yeah that was not the
intended consequence of the 20 grand at
the time exactly right and you and you
and you can kind of you know disavow
them try to go in and coach them and
whatnot but I think that part of the Y
Combinator conversation should be in
this should this exist direction I think
it's important and and I think it's also
important that another thing too is that
we have a um we wrote this thing called
the founder the co-founder charter which
is a conversation that co-founders have
and I'm sure that Y commenter has some
version of this as well where you kind
of set out your expectations your hopes
and dreams for the company and where you
would want to go but I think it's really
important also to put down in that
document you know what you will and
won't do like where where are the limits
if you're if you're in AI you know or
you're in CRISPR or you're in one of
these kind of emerging categories it's
like an ethical minefield yeah you know
really no we're we will and won't go
what for do you make all of the founders
that you invest in fill out this charter
no no we don't I mean we it's kind of
offered and we kind of have the
conversation we encourage that
conversation is not required but I think
that our our founders tend to be of a
certain kind and if you look at all of
my prior companies my prior investments
they do have a certain flavor there's a
certain dose that that they have in
common so you know Flickr was an online
community there were kind of it was a
very human community we're creative very
communicative and you know other
companies that I've been part of include
Etsy where I was like the fourth or
fifth person there are
on the founding team and then became the
chairman up through its I mean you know
and then you know other companies that I
have funded like Kickstarter they have a
very I think human ethos absolutely and
the the kind of technology that I've
always hoped to build and and part of
the reason I'm doing this podcast is
that I've always seen a big part of my
job as me Katarina fake is actually to
humanize technology because it can it
can dehumanize us and it has a tendency
to do that
if we if it goes in certain directions
and to constantly bring it back you know
to the human to the relational to the
interpersonal to the communitarian to
the creativity all of those things about
us and they're all they're all so all
these structures that you're working
within because I think people could say
like well you know VC is inherently
prone to being susceptible to all of
these vices right because yes you've the
money you're like here I'm gonna be X
amount of money for y percent and it
assumes a certain amount of like
hopefully infinite growth right and
people will just like beg borrow and
steal to get that number so they can
increasing the valuation so they can
keep raising so they can you know exit
but you exist saying you know and I
think YC is in a similar boat yeah that
doesn't necessarily have to be true
right but it's painted that way so many
conversations that are going on right
now about the VC model of course that I
think are great and and everybody
questioning the unicorn with scaling you
know 99 must die for one to succeed
model which I think that that for for
you know decades has been taken as the
single path to a successful Valley
venture funded company which is why you
end up with the you know the the venture
back sociopaths and the you know these
cut like truly like it was like it kind
of it actually kind of puts you in the
position where you have to become a
worse person right you have to change
your goals and your desires and who it
is that you become and I worked on Wall
Street for six months okay so as long as
I could I could actually have is that
when you're really the
or assistant you mentioned this in the
other podcast I listen to you were there
writing a novel or something I was a
reception reception yeah who is a
painter like literally a painter making
like nothing literally nothing I was I
was I was I was living on like there was
a place like great in New York today it
was called Gray's papaya where famously
you could get a 99 cent hotdogs yeah
near my house right 99 cent hotdogs and
a soda it was like it like this is like
lowest and nutrition period of my life
yeah sure how I survived it I was like
thin as a rail but I was a painter and I
and I took all these temp jobs and I had
a temp job at a investment bank and the
managing director of this department
came to me and he said ooh you know kid
I was only like in my twenties super
young early twenties and you're really
smart you could be an analyst here and
I'm like well you know I'm a painter and
you know it's kind of not my desire he
said yeah but I'm gonna pay you a
six-figure salary right I don't like
sushi or sangria like I'm living on like
99 cent hotdogs at this point so I'm
like okay I I think I can take you up on
that so I went out and I bought myself
like literally I bought myself a suit
like a power suit like some shoes right
cuz I'm working on Wall Street and I
have to like I can't look like a
receptionist anywhere I'm like an animal
I'm like the real tail so I I step in
and within six months I found myself
becoming a different person this was the
thing that I knew did in myself I was
surrounded by it was all guys right was
like me and a bunch of guys right and I
was as tough as any of them great it was
kind of I was just tough as any of them
they were so impressed by me they
started calling me brass balls it's like
it's Wall Street right it was very warm
wolf of Wall Street kind of environment
totally wolf of Wall Street environment
and I and yet I could be just as
obnoxious as them and that's what they
liked about me and I didn't like that
that was what they liked about me they
didn't like my kind leur gentler more
thoughtful poetic painterly qualities
they liked the fact that I
just rise up or down like lowered myself
down to their level yeah right I could
kind of meet them where they were and
just be like I can give as good as I get
here and then I realized what was
happening to me as I went so literally
that was like six months of that
experience where I was just becoming you
know the Wolverine of Wall Street and I
didn't want to become that and so I was
what happened was I was I got off the
subway on Fifth Avenue in New York where
I was living and was on my way to work
and I remember I was I had just become
so angry all the time
and that I was walking down the street
and I was refusing to move aside for
other people right because I was just
like in this world of I don't know like
I was some kind of like an elite
entitled person yeah yeah it was awful
like it was truly I was transforming
into just the most terrific person and
it was actually when I was standing
there on the sidewalk unwilling to move
aside for other people that I realized
that I had to quit and I walked in and I
quit that day because I was just like
it's not worth it like this is the end
of this is the end of you then you've
become a monster it's very self-aware a
lot of people do 20 years before they I
was gonna say you realize that you know
and I was like I was I was like I was
back to 99 so hot dogs I was good at
saving so yeah entirely true but you
know yeah like and so that was it that
was a kind of a big moment I think it's
dangerous right you get part of a
certain culture and then you want to be
good at the game yeah and we've seen the
valley this is the game I'm in and I'm
gonna mold myself to make it work great
right and that was the game and I'm good
at the game I can always figure out
things exactly
I can always figure out the game right
right like that's one of my like my
special sauce is that I would get in the
system so for example school should we
should talk we should talk about this
because I I was a horrible student pray
I was a great student and I was a
horrible student I liked to learn but it
didn't like to be taught and so I had
you know I would go to class I would you
know you know for example like eighth
grade
geology I was like this is great I've
been collecting rocks my whole life I'm
so into this so I like sat down and read
the geology textbook yeah and I was like
oh I love this subject is so great so I
showed up for class the second class and
I realized that the teacher is just
gonna read out of the textbook which it
just wrote which I just read yeah and
something like this is horrible I'm not
gonna bother doing this so I so I
laughed and they you know I kept on
getting you know marked absent I was a
truant
my parents had to come in and talk to
the principal and all these got to make
me back go back into class again so in
order to get around this I would read I
would check out of the library
I get interlibrary loan I would get all
of the books of the bibliography of each
of the chapters on my geology textbook
and I would read them and then I would
sit in the front row and the teacher was
like hey you know buh buh buh buhbuh
buhbuh buhbuh buh
plate tectonics this and i was like you
know if you had read would raise my hand
if you had read the seminal paper and
plate tectonics you would realize that
blob that was like there most of my went
over incredibly poorly which is kind of
the design yeah and then I was excused
from class and she kind of took me aside
and said if you just show up for the
exam you know I will not report you
absent anymore so I did all of these
like weird workarounds and then I I kind
of just would and it wasn't like I was
off like smoking dope like behind the
bushes like I was actually in the
library no reading so it wasn't like I
was a bad student but I was truly like
institutions and I have never gotten
along well and so I was you know I was
always like that and I and I discovered
that if you did really well on
standardized tests you were good
right yeah so I was like I was one of
those students where I had like you know
straight C's and then occasionally I
would get like eight pluses in the
classroom I had a really stellar teacher
and I just loved them and I would do
everything like that I could and then I
had all these seasoned like I was always
on the verge of getting kicked out and
and yet I was like a National Merit
Scholar yeah right so I had this I had
this like peculiar relationship to to to
school and to education I was there were
a lot of P
there who had like so much better grades
than I did I was I did not get good
grades its but it worked out okay for
you so now Jane yeah right
do you feel that school is is doing it
disservice to many people or are you
just a small percentage of the world
where you're like I don't know I was
never gonna fit in here and so I can
succeed as an entrepreneur I mean I do
think that that nature right that
virtually but peculiar Eddie is actually
very common yeah come on entrepreneurs I
think so too yeah that tendency to look
at existing frameworks in which you're
being forced to fit and and just say
like I don't fit into this framework
like this this frame right is not
serving people how can we well you can
also change that or somehow adapt in a
different way and forge your own path
and you have to kind of be like I said
have a lot of initiative right like you
cannot go to class because you don't
want to do the work where you cannot go
to class because you read all of the
books in the bibliography on plate
tectonic I'm saying like you can you can
you can there's different approaches
right there's different reasons to not
go to class yeah yeah and if you're not
going to class for the right reasons in
the end I think it will serve you yeah
right it's hard to have that confidence
when you're younger right just be like
oh dude this is all like all these
wheels are made up I know but like I
think that you have to look into
yourself really deeply and ask yourself
you know do I really like is this
something that's actually truly
worthwhile and to not fight to win
prizes not worth winning
right so much of life is that yeah and
switch it up so what I'm actually
curious about both of you like who did
you look up to when you were younger
what was there someone oh man I could
you know I could be like them ah that's
a good question I don't do you have an
answer I think to of
people who you know is what I eat I
think about it personally and I'm like
you know I don't school I was it fine
like it was no problem it was not
particularly difficult to get a B or any
-
but I was like I don't think I want to
win this game
right yeah yes not where I fit in and so
I would just look around and see like oh
you know like Spike Jonze it's like he's
making videos he's making skateboard
videos he's also starting yeah but he's
doing all this creative work that's so
awesome right so there is a model right
sure right and it's interesting too
because they're like you say Spike Lee
is kind of a great example like that
this week I'm sorry Spike Jonze sorry um
but like Spike Jonze and you know it's
so funny because um when I was living in
New York around that same time spec
Jones was living down in alleged gallery
down on the Lower East Side on Ludlow
Street and I used to go hang out with
those guys and they were publishing a
magazine called dirt
yeah do you remember them or were you
like awareness so we thought that this
was the coolest thing ever because it
was and I remember one of the things
that I learned from that was had it how
to deface it's illegal how did you face
a Canadian v to turn the you know the
old white dude on the five dollar
Canadian Bell into a Leonard Nimoy's
like mr. mr. Spock yeah rate which was
so like I remember that I was like
actually from like an early issue and
they had so many like things like that
that were like quasi illegal in dirt and
I remember saw a show this thing like
how to drill a hole in a quarter so that
you could use it repeatedly at the
laundromat if I know to do these like
things like like a thousand things like
this and I'm like you know can you
publish things it's like oh there are
these like Fringe examples of works
Fraser you know what's interesting
though and here's the thing that's kind
of interesting
yeah is that what was on this always
happens right what was on the edge
became the center told right three years
ago ten years ago doing would start up
sent right individual founders being
able to build enormous companies that
did just didn't happen right and also
you know kind of you know culturally
rebellion was actually rebellion against
the system and now you're kind of in
it's on that you're on the inside oh
yeah you know you're kind of being asked
to disrupt yeah right and and that's a
complete change I think in culture it's
I mean you know obviously it's been
happening since I don't know that since
Levi's right you know became like you
know like $600 jeans right like you know
I'm saying like it's like it used to be
just totally rebellious actually
rebellious to wear Levi's I mean now
it's kind of hard to say right but yeah
I've heard the comparison multiple times
that like you know Facebook jobs are the
same as the Goldman job ten years ago I
think it's kind of true it's kind of
true I mean how much is an entry-level
Facebook employee make six figures I
assume yeah six figures yeah right
I mean like you get a painter yeah you
know yeah sitting behind a reception
task at a at an investment bank yeah
yeah in in the late nineties so do you
have answers we move on do you have
answer Oh about who we looked up to as
kids I don't think I'll get back to you
on that I mean I know there's so many
super interesting because I think that
there's kind of cultural yours you know
Spike Jonze being a great example like
there's there's kind of cultural icons
yeah that are not necessarily people
you're gonna like you didn't become know
a skipper - filmmaker no kind of media
person right but you recognized in
certain people a spirit that you thought
was something that you related to and
wanted to follow know where emulate or
you know you kind of just took his
inspiration and and so as you are
homeschooling is that something that you
try and set up and for your kids
I couldn't have to find those yourself
yeah saying like you can't just I mean
like your parents no thank you
no I mean I do think that you have to
you know provide a rich environment in
which those possibilities are there
present yeah I am what I'm really
thankful for today is that I was
thinking through like all the people
that I looked up to and only one woman
comes to mind from being a kid right I
really liked last longer
who is this I'm Filipino right and who
was his Filipino artist and and
performer last along but she was the
voice of Prince Jasmine okay then you
know we should know and so now I think
that there's and I think what it was is
just seeing a Filipino woman who is
successful out in the world oh yeah and
and put on a pedestal and people really
appreciated her work I didn't know any
other Filipino women that were featured
anywhere and so I think I think it's so
great now that there's way more women in
all industries that are featured yeah
some of who are and so I'm not that's
something that means a lot to me is that
is seeing someone who looks like you or
represents sort of the background that
you came from right owning it I mean III
think this is really important honestly
if you're an underrepresented yeah right
to see you're kind of what next hero to
see your yeah you know you know Filipina
hero I you know I think it's important
yeah yeah absolutely I mean I where's
Diane Eisner like you did yeah go get
Jollibee together so Jollibee used to be
a couple blocks of yeah yeah do they
happen in ketchup at the Jollibee I
don't think so I could never get into
this wheat pasta situation yeah it's a
thing you have to grab it might be an
acquired taste so we have some questions
from Twitter
that would be kind of fun to cover okay
Ken okay so let's see we have many
questions so I think this could be kind
of interesting so how did you get your
first 100 users but now you've started
three separate companies so there's rain
flicker hunch finery right did you apply
the same strategies for all of them
they're different it gets easier as you
go along I started on maybe I didn't
like kind of start from second base but
I you know I started from first base at
least I was already on base like in that
I had a I had a blog okay that had a lot
of followers and I had started this very
early early on and so it was literally
drawing from my existing community and
the people that I already knew who who
then were invited to and participated in
you have to you know you start small you
start where you are with what you've got
and and I had I had the advantage of
having been very gregarious online for
several years before starting Flickr
which is where our initial our initial
user base came from you were just
blogging I was blogging I started a blog
in 1998 nice and it was what platform 2g
is it was on the first one was actually
just written in HTML no actually yeah so
you just put up a patient's literally in
HTML and then sometime around that time
there's blogging software appeared yeah
which was kind of a revelation there are
always things like geo cities and this
is starting to sound like kind of
grandpa and the creaking rocking chair
talking about like when I was a kid it
was like geo cities in diary land and
all these kinds of things really like
back in the olden days and then bloggers
came out and then movable-type mm-hmm
yeah which eventually became WordPress
and and so I started using both of those
actually I just found
my blogger archives online which was
kind of amazing to find and so I've had
this blah I've had the blog which I
maintain to this day at Caterina dotnet
which you know I had started in circa
1998 roughly around then when I got my
handwritten reverse cron right yeah you
know blogs Luke literally and and and
there wasn't any blogging software at
the time and so not only that but the
blogging community was actually very
small and so we all knew each other
I knew Mina tribe from movable-type I
knew F Williams from blogger I knew all
of these people and it was just a very
very small and very rich community
actually very close we all read each
other's stuff and so it was it was a
really great core mm-hmm community to
start with not only that but they had
the ability to talk about new things
including your photo sharing products
mm-hm
but it's interesting because I you know
one thing that I should know is that the
way that Flickr really took off okay was
that it was at the time thought to be
extremely expensive to serve photos
right and it was but we knew that the
cost of storage was declining in the
cost of serving photos was declining and
more people had broadband at their house
you know we're talking about like circa
2003 and it seemed counterintuitive to
allow people to hotlink quote-unquote
your photo your photos to your blog yeah
and so but we realized that actually it
wasn't going to be that expensive
because of class the costs were just
declining you know month over month and
so the way that Flickr really got going
was when we allowed people to embed
their photos on their blog because
bloggers and movable-type neither of
them had the ability to serve photos and
one crucial thing happened is the number
one question that was asked on the
FAQ mm-hmm was where do I host my photos
and the guy who wrote the FAQ wrote
Flickr Wow Flickr is the place that you
can put your photos and so then people
started using it did you guys have some
like watermark type thing going on yeah
yeah we said like we're happy to host
your photos yeah so long as you link
back to Flickr yeah right
it's what happened with imager and
running same thing and so and and and I
think that that was that was tremendous
because suddenly we were on blogs all
over the place I'd be like oh well you
know obviously if you're gonna have a
photo and eventually they did enable
people to upload photos to bloggers but
it was a long time coming and in that
intervening you know several months yeah
we just grew like crazy interesting yeah
I mean I heard the same thing about um
twitch writing their own encoder like
they realize like there was like this
massive cost savings at the certain
point in time and that's what allowed
them to become profitable sure to become
this gigantic company right right right
cuz you could kind of see like the you
know the cost of mic you know you know
storage and man West sac lining like
this you could just see it happen and
you kind of knew what that trajectory
was gonna end up at and you know yeah
you're losing money now but you won't be
losing money later
interesting yeah so yes okay so as so
basically you created your own like
little personal brand like back in the
day I would never call it a person I
know all the time and you're sharing
this designer historically like
historically I was so so that's kind of
how I got into the internet yeah because
like I was this painter who failed at
Wall Street for various reasons yeah and
then moved to California because my
sister was out here and the web was
happening and I thought to myself oh
well I can parlay my aesthetic skills
into a design job yeah and I didn't you
had a code like I was always I was
always very nerdy kid and I had my own
computers and I knew how to kind of
really do basic very basic programming
but you know I always had an interest in
so that's how I got started I you know I
kind of was self-taught and then what
about when you're when you're an
investor what are the things you're
looking for and Founder so like these
are kind of ways as a founder you can
might you might be able to attract more
users right now as a founder earned as
an investor now do you attract investors
is it just as simple as I can make
something people want make something
great yeah I mean yes and no because you
can actually make something that people
want desperately and I won't workout so
I think a really instructive study was
done by Bill Gross yeah rate of Idealab
who I don't know how many like 500
companies have gone through there and at
some point you know they had a they had
a very large pool of companies that they
had incubated they're you know kind of
was like you know why comment here
before my comment yeah and it was like
90s not Y common air and he looked at
the companies that had succeeded and
those that had failed and they looked at
a bunch of different aspects that you
could measure the companies in was it in
a large market did it have you know did
it have a very strong founding team were
they execution oriented brewer was their
timing right were they first to market
all of these different things that
investors had historically looked at as
as leading to the success or not of this
company he found that without a doubt
the single biggest factor of the success
of the companies was not the individual
contributors their business plan their
you know market but their timing yeah
mm-hmm and I know this because Flickr
came out at a point when Friendster had
already gotten people used to the idea
of putting their pictures online and
having an online profile number one
number two more than half of US
households had broadband could download
a photo like literally and three more
than half of the cellphones were
shipping with a camera no like it was
unstoppable it was a juggernaut it grew
so fast and um you know its timing was
perfect it was perfect timing
and I know this too because you know
other companies that I have built hunch
I think hunch was about five years too
early right and I think that finder II
was about two years too late and it's
super interesting how these how these
these things work out and so when we're
investors in @yes VC when we look at
investments we try to find what we're
calling movements we looked at those
companies that I mentioned earlier Etsy
Kickstarter cloud era was an investor
you know was an investment and and what
what was happening around them what was
the time like what was timed right Etsy
came to emblem ah I like kind of like
represent the DIY handmade anti big-box
retail movement it was a movement mhm
right mmm and it's funny because I took
it all around the valley and I took it
too you know it's like kind of like
big-name investors all of whom you've
like know well and I've heard of and
like they're all kind of like wait so
let me get this straight
it's a bunch of women the city around
knitting sweaters and selling it to each
other
and I'm like exactly it's gonna be huge
great they could not see it alright but
you got to understand there's this like
groundswell and it literally the next
decade yeah was about handmade this and
art isn't all that right as an investor
in Blue Bottle coffee it was the same
thing was like artisanal food was just
like like the decade was about that
you know cloud era was like open source
Kickstarter like basically came to
represent you know crowdfunding yeah
right yeah so so when you actually look
at the cultural changes that are
happening around your product if you
have the ability to spot a movement like
that a big cultural movement like that
everybody's traveling in the same
direction the reporters and the
journalists you want to report on that
people are suddenly becoming conscious
of the fact that they can have artisanal
pickles really we don't need an
artisanal pickles but suddenly everybody
is like desiring them
you seem saying like so there's there's
this sort of groundswell of movement
like you're just like you're you're a
surfer our main you see the big wave and
you're like I am on that wave and you
know being able to kind of see that whom
you're kind of I you know in your heart
you know and like all of your kind of
senses towards that you know is
tremendous so if you can like because
everything everything around you wants
you to succeed
yeah yeah right and so if you can find
that like as an investor that's like you
know that's an amazing thing and as a
founder as well that's the thing and as
a founder as well like honestly you know
figure out the thing not just make
something that people want because a lot
of time you can make something that
people want but you know not enough
people want it or they're not aware that
they wanted or like the cultures like
kind of gone beyond it or more specially
if they're taking VC taking venture yeah
so okay so wrapping up people can find
should this exists on iTunes yeah well
link yes excellent cool I'm sure it's
gonna be great
but if I'm a founder what questions like
should I ask if I should maybe should
this exists like should I make this
thing right there's so many there's a
really good kind of framework for asking
these questions and I honestly think
it's not just a single question and it's
not at a single time right I think it's
something that you just have to build
into your process mm-hmm as founders and
as employees actually because you know I
there's more people joining startups
than founding startups so I think it's
the responsibility of a lot of people on
the team like you mentioned earlier to
be just just asking that question should
this exists and it can be the same
question I mean at different points in
the game right if I make this decision
about the design of the recent activity
so called feed yeah is this should this
exists like is this a feature that
people want or need is this going to end
up like let's let's do a thought
experiment
just like sit down and kind of imagine
if this thing becomes the thing that
millions of people use just like think
it through right and then put on your
ear kind of doomsday scenario huh
right your science fiction science
fiction dystopian novelist hat yeah and
say to yourself is this is that like so
like let's say I'm just you know the
most pessimistic person on the planet
find the pessimists around you we've all
got them in our lives all right today
especially stand out to entrepreneurs
because really they're they're looking
at things this way and we're looking at
things that way so bring them in and say
like look and those people who are just
kind of no no that's you know that's bad
it's gonna be bad like listen to listen
to them you kind of figure out okay are
they right right are they right like
could descend up there and and you know
kind of just like sometimes just seeing
it for the first time isn't I feel like
ooh we're gonna change that feature or
we're gonna build an admin function that
prevents that from happening or we're
gonna take a totally different data set
and feed it into our AI so that we don't
have that outcome so that's it I think
that's great well thank you for coming
thank you thank you so much this has
been fun yeah
you